[Musique]
rassemblez pollinisent est le thème de
cette rencontre musicale
elle est placée sous le signe de la
solidarité un soutien aux salariés mais
aussi aux gérants de ce restaurant situé
au bord de la plage de l'hôtel la
batelière à schoelcher la clientèle
sensibiliser au litige opposant le
restaurant le lui dise à la société cari
d'investissement gestionnaires de
l'hôtel a répondu massivement à
l'invitation
donc j'ai eu le partage facebook de
cette mobilisation
donc j'ai tenu justement à
allez comment dirais-je à les soutenir
on est venus là en famille franchement
c'est agréable ça serait bien dommage de
fermer deux lieux ces magnifiques repas
trappeur parce que on laisse hélas le
lieu de rencontre moi je trouve que ici
c'est très accueillants je comprends pas
pourquoi cela fait 1 me mais en tout cas
on les soutient à fond et voilà tu pas
très d'accord parce que j'aime bien chez
eux ce serait dommage que cela
disparaisse de nouvelles demandes
d'actes et de l'occupation temporaire du
domaine public maritime du fond de mer
ont été introduites auprès de la ddt et
al l'une pour la santé car
investissements et l'autre par les
gérants du 10/10 beach ils sont en ce
moment dans la tente
ça fait plus de onze ans qu'on exploite
ce site je pense pour le plus grand
bonheur des martiniquais et des
touristes de passage et on espère
simplement continuer comme ça savoir
qu'on a plus de 45 salariés
on est tous soudés ils ont envie de
continuer à travailler dans cette
ambiance et on espère que ça va durer
longtemps
un vaste projet de rénovation incluant
la remise aux normes de ce restaurant
mais aussi de toute la structure de
l'hôtel est envisagée par le groupe
monplaisir le directeur de l'hôtel se
veut rassurant quant à la reprise de
tous les salariés d'une église
aujourd'hui les salariés ni noms n'ont
finalement pas être inquiétés puisque ce
sont deux structures qui fonctionnent
qui se propose de les embaucher
donc soit le lisent soit si
effectivement l'hôtel batelière reprend
la gestion de la plage les salariés
seront repris de façon intégrale par
l'hôtel batelière
pour l'heure les deux parties assistés
de leurs avocats attendent impatiemment
la décision de la dea
elle devra intervenir normalement avant
la fin du mois de janvier 2020